les sciences c'est une découverte qui
est présenté comme très importante
contre les principales maladies
des chercheurs sont parvenus à
transformer des cellules de peau humaine
en cellules souches
ces organismes peuvent vous le savez
régénérer les tissus ou les organes
endommagés
explication nicolas chateauneuf laurence
beauvillard diane richard c'est une
simple cellules de peau humaine mais
elle représente peut être une révolution
dans la recherche médicale
au même moment deux équipes l'une
japonaise l'autre américaine viennent
d'annoncer qu'elle avait découvert un
nouveau moyen beaucoup plus facile de
produire des cellules souches
les deux équipes ont prélevé de la peau
sur des adultes par un processus
complexe ils en ont tiré des cellules
souches capables à terme d'évoluer en
n'importe quelles cellules du corps
humain muscles nerfs hausse et bien
d'autres encore
avec cette méthode si l'on veut
peut-être dans l'avenir soigner une
maladie du cerveau du coeur on pourra
prendre des cellules de la peau de cette
personne
les transformer en cellules souche
identique aux cellules de la personne
leur recommander de se transformer en
cellules du cerveau et de coeur et
peut-être les soigner peut-être les
guérillas jusqu'à maintenant pour
obtenir des cellules souches il fallait
recourir au clonage thérapeutique aux
cellules embryonnaires qui pose des
problèmes éthiques
grâce à cette nouvelle technique pas de
risque de rejet puisque les cellules
souches proviendront du patient lui même
à terme cette découverte permettra
peut-être d'avancer beaucoup plus
rapidement dans la connaissance de
maladies comme le cancer alzheimer
parkinson ou le diabète
une brèche dans laquelle s'engouffrent
déjà de nombreuses équipes scientifiques